It's my honor to be part of this great event...
...and my name is Hiroshi Mikitani,...
...and I'm the CEO and founder of a Japanese Internet company called "Rakuten".
We started our company in 1997.
We started from scratch with my younger partner...
...who was a graduate school student at that time.
Unlike our competitors in the United States, we started from our own capital,...
...which was 200,000 dollars...
...and never raised any money from VCs.
I'm sure there are so many venture capital people here, sorry to tell you about that, but...
...never raised any money from VC.
We went public in the year 2000....
...and we cultivated the first boat, the last boat of the first Internet bubble.
So, we raised about 500 million dollars from our IPO,...
...and since then, we have been aggressively expanding our business...
...in terms of scope and in terms of scale.
Now, we are by far number 1 in e-commerce, number 1 in online travel,...
...number 1 in online banking, number 2 in online brokerage.
So, we have about 38 Internet-related businesses and market cap of about 11 billion dollars,...
...but one thing we know is we have been a very Japan-centric company.
We didn't expand globally...
...up to three or four years ago.
Whereby our competitors like Google, Amazon, eBay...
...have aggressively expanded their businesses into other countries...
...so now, we have decided to grow our service band...
...and I think, now, we converted the internal language...
...of our company from Japanese to English,...
...which I don't think there's any Japanese company who really tried to do it.
And we believe our business model is very unique,...
...but I think we can really execute what we have done in Japan in other countries.
And I'm really looking forward to sharing my experience, and I have a work session in the afternoon,...
...and looking forward to, you know, exchanging any ideas. Thank you very much!